In Germany, European Union foreign ministers are set to discuss...
...the growing immigration crisis as search and rescue operations continue...
...in the Mediterranean for missing migrants.
In Somalia, the militant group al-Shabab claims responsibility for a bomb attack...
...on a UN bus that killed at least seven people and wounded several others.
In Pakistan, Chinese President Xi Jinping arrives in Islamabad for his first state visit,...
...where he is expected to announce a development project worth 46 billion dollars.
At least two candidates running in municipal elections in Cuba...
...are unaffiliated with Castro's government for the first time since the 1959 revolution.
And finally from the Philippines, US and Philippine soldiers...
...begin their biggest combined military exercise in 15 years.